good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 714 object class
safe special containment procedures SCP
714 is to be stored in a reinforced
high-security locker that is accessible
to only level 4 plus personnel due to
several incidents of misuse description
seemingly nothing more than a green jade
ring SCP 714 has been shown to be able
to expand and contract to perfectly fit
the finger of anyone who touches it
though this is the least important of
its properties SCP 714 only changes size
when touched by a new subject SCP 714
has several major effects detailed as
follows
number one exhaustion compulsion to rest
or sleep within minutes of putting on
SCP 714 wearer's report feeling worn out
physically and mentally exhausted due to
this they will feel driven to sit down
and rest for a bit on the nearest
available furniture and will likely fall
asleep within the space of a few hours
if someone falls asleep wearing SCP 714
the only known means of waking them up
is to remove SCP 714 at which point they
may be roused by anything that would
normally wake them up exhaustion effects
pass within two or three hours of
removing SCP 714 if removed from a
conscious subject those that fall asleep
wearing a CP 7:14 report feeling well
arrested if SCP 714 is removed even if
they've only slept for a few minutes
SCP 7:14 extends no considerations
towards the needs of its wearer during
their forced sleep though most bodily
functions such as breathing continue if
SCP 714 is not removed
the wearer woken up most will die of
dehydration or starvation within a
matter of days as CP 714 impact if any
on Aging remains untested where's that
are tired prior to putting a CP 714 are
at serious risk of falling asleep on
their feet possibly falling over in the
process if no furniture or furniture
like object is available nearby wears
either stand on the spot they donned SCP
7:14 or attempt to fashion a resting
place out of any suitable materials
cushions blankets etc available the
drive to sleep can be resisted but
requires formidable willpower and
self-control on the part of the wearer
even so the following effect makes it
impractical for field use number 2
slowed reactions sluggish movement
subjects suffer from severely impaired
reaction times a normally sharp alert
and physically fit subject can have a
hard time catching a slow moving object
thrown to them even if warned and given
ample time to prepare anyone wearing SCP
714 should not be allowed to operate any
heavy machinery or other vehicles under
any circumstances wearers of SCP 7:14
move much slower than normal
managing an average walking pace at best
their movements are not physically
slower but they are incapable of
exerting themselves
number three reduced mental capacity
seemingly as part of the mental fatigue
anyone wearing a CP 714 claims that they
think slowly or may even have trouble
finding the words to adequately
communicate that they cannot think as
clearly as normal the wearer may take a
long time to think of an answer to a
trivial question for example what color
is this red ball they remind one that is
vague or requires a more complicated
response with removal of SCP 714 mental
capacities restored to normal within a
few minutes number four mental shield is
a dubious benefit of seemingly reduced
mental capacity wearers of SCP 714 show
abnormally high resilience to memetic
and mental influences particularly
commands or immediate effects weaker
mimetic influences may be totally
nullified by this in both cases the
wearer feels a strong and instinctive
fear of the source of the influence this
fear drives them to immediately seek
shelter by any means available
potentially by attempting to destroy the
source the shielding lasts only for as
long as SCP 714 is worn they are still
at significant risk of exposed to any
mimetic influences that do not take
immediate effect exposure to such
influences should be handled as normal
for the source in question as the degree
of protection afforded by a CP 714 has
yet to be fully documented in addition
normal images and sounds that would
cause revulsion nausea etc simply due to
shocking or disturbing content have next
to no effect on the wearer of SCP 714
the wearer will not even recall seeing
them once SCP 714 is removed mundane
persuasion such as motivational speeches
have no effect regardless of the
speaker's skill and charisma
number five chemical tolerance just as
their minds blocked mimetic effects the
bombings of SCP 714 wearers slows and
nullifies the effects of various
chemicals on the body fully poisonous or
toxic substances are generally not
hindered but those that specifically
impede or enhance neural and or nervous
functions in some way such as stimulants
or sedatives have very diminished
effects with removal of SCP 714 this
Nullification effect expires instantly
wearers may still suffer from standard
overdose effects whilst wearing a CP 714
the manner or manners in which SCP 714
causes its various effects has yet to be
discovered and no unusual emissions of
any kind have been detected despite
extensive monitoring
if SCP 714 is significantly damaged in
any way such as being broken into two or
more pieces its effects will cease
immediately if the pieces of SCP 714 are
then placed within close proximity they
will gradually reform into a whole copy
of a CP 714 flowing as if made of liquid
once SCP 714 is fully formed its
functions return as if it were never
damaged grinding SCP 714 down to a fine
powder did nothing to impede its
self-repair behavior either though the
process did take considerably longer
though the exact nature of this
self-repair behaviour has not been
determined as of this time it is thought
SCP 714 could theoretically recover from
complete vaporization however due to SCP
714 s low threat level this has been
deemed an unnecessary use of resources
footage sequences of SCP 7:14 reforming
from various states of disrepair are
available upon request from doctor
or other appropriate sources attempts to
track the history and ownership of SCP
714 have proven futile due to the nature
of its recovery agent reported feeling
abnormally drowsy even after several
mugs of strong coffee and was found to
be wearing SCP 7:14 with no memory of
having come into possession of it agent
has been reprimanded as appropriate that
measures have been taken to ensure SCP
714 stays in its locker at all times
the draining effects and compulsion to
rest make use of SCP 7:14 as a
protective measure against certain scps
highly impractical at this time
SCP 714 is not believed do you have any
other serious effects beyond the danger
of dehydration and starvation of
personnel who fall asleep wearing a CP
7:14 as a result of being unable to
rouse themselves or sustenance
experimentation notes text transcripts
of audio logs compiled by dr. entry off
May 1st 2000 so far all attempts to find
the cause of SCP 714 s effects have
proven fruitless I don't think I need to
emphasize how useful this could be if we
could pull it off without the negative
effects but so far everything we've
tried has come up with blanks hence SCP
714 s ongoing safe euclid classification
we know what it does but not how it does
it as much as I want to say it's 100%
safe there's something about it that's
not quite right Andreea of May 12 2008
trying to acquire a date on SCP 714 has
given us mixed results parts of a date
back as far as very early ad circle 100
to 200 and are probably from China other
samples are relatively speaking more
recent like it's been made out of
multiple pieces though it is without
question a structurally flawless jade
ring on the plus side we've had some
luck finding out who owned it before
thanks to a string of reports of Jade
statuettes going missing when a ring
matching a cp7 14s description was in
close proximity to them what a
coincidence hmm perhaps SCP 714 s
curious regenerative and size changing
capabilities stem from for lack of a
better term assimilating other pieces of
jade analysis has shown that SCP 714 is
much higher density than average Jade
but as apparently no heavier would be
some form of extra dimensional storage
as weird as that sounds
sure is one way of carrying the weight
of the world on your shoulders
entry of May 27th 2000 okay so a bit
more luck on the tracking front it was
originally found in the late 1800s that
is around the 1870s to the 1880s by an
archaeologist who traveled around the
world seeking Jade artifacts such as
statuettes and figurines that might be
found in tombs or forgotten temples he
was hunting in tombs said to be rich in
them
of course he eventually found and
entered it finding only SCP 7:14 in
terms of jade artifacts puzzling very
few historical documents describe
anything that matches SCP 7:14 so it's
hard to say how old it really is vexing
the archaeologists personal Diaries have
not survived the ages well unfortunately
and his handwriting leaves much to be
desired
so it's difficult to tell whether or not
he wore SCP 714 and the documented
effects of it whilst it was in his
possession or whether he never
considered wearing it what I can make
out is that he quickly disposed of the
ring after a number of his collection
pieces went missing after spending the
night in proximity to the ring with no
signs of breakin or theft
[Music]
okay I think that about does it for
today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you are all
dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to pierce M Hamlin Muslim
Mookie slump God dr. day John o quarter
captain Gorge fluffy sky key man a moon
a my archive curator Nick tie verbal OD
tench cheese whip
I'm Depp's McGee thank you all so much
for your support I really appreciate it
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos on some
other cool stuff as well is it
patreon.com forward slash the Vulcan
thank you
you